bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono un po vj oggi
andiamo avanti con stendardi arrivo le
rom rimasti che eravamo riusciti a
salire da questo ascensore assurdo
praticamente siamo in una dovremmo
essere su una torre credo in un idea di
dove siamo sinceramente c'è qualcosa qui
una pagina la numero 8 e gioie to call
of duty dosi nof times square arie brees
colmi back e al minor fior key di faido
sirback in power è in coma
ok perfetto mi fa piacere vieni oddio
cos'è perché siamo fuori scusa cioè sono
salito da un ascensore
mi spiegate perchè cazzo sono fuori non
ha senso ha si vede che sono tipo su una
montagna era un passaggio per salire
bene sono in alto essere in alto
sinceramente mi mette un po più di
tranquillità ma in generale credo che io
non debba tranquillizzarmi più di tanto
comunque abbiamo fatto tutto il casino
per salire perché ci ho messo un secolo
e che cosa stiamo facendo adesso stiamo
scendendo porca [ __ ] c'è ma ho passato
una puntata a fare casini per riuscire a
scappare da uno stupratore di merda e
adesso che cosa faccio niente scendo la
montagna piedi tranquillamente va beh
facciamo finta di niente andiamo avanti
c'è una radura madonna che cazzo ma che
cazzo di posto cioè raga io mi sto
avvicinando sempre di più a quella roba
lì è come ambientazione vi giuro mi
sembra mi ricorda troppo alan wake
guardate che roba oh mio dio questo è il
paradiso dello slider di notte c'è una
cosa veramente assurda non
immaginatevelo di notte perché spero che
io non debba andare
perché ci metterei giusto un po ad
uscire no vabbè spero vivamente di non
andare vi perché sarebbe traumatico
proseguiamo comunque per il sentiero
anche se mi fa veramente paura a
guardare di sotto
sono sicuro che lui e da qualche parte
in questo momento che mi sta osservando
sono sicuro vabbè
noi proseguiamo lo stesso allora andiamo
avanti finché giorno sono tranquillo ma
tanto so già che la notte carriera o che
cazzo è o di un bengala è passato di qui
alla wake perché se un bengala vabbè
prendi lo fa qualcosa di che cazzo è sto
bengala vabbè fa niente noi andiamo
avanti alan sei tu a lato dio lo sta
diventando buiona la torcia torcia torce
ok sta diventando buio perché sono in
una caverna sono idiota perché
effettivamente ancora giorno fuori
fantastico sono veramente contento che
dopo una mappa come quella di prima ci
sia un pochettino di relax anche se
spero anche se penso che comunque non
duri tanto eye want to die parla per te
idiota passate una bella giornata
insieme io me ne vado dio cos'è che
cazzo e questo è un porno cos'è sta roba
è sarde buongiorno è una webcam mi vedi
perché sento dei passi che cazzo succede
sono entrato nel televisore sono io tipo
la bambina di the ring
ok questa è la casa di prima e la casa
del primo episodio raga
c'è qualcosa per i dalla fico dio oddio
no no vi prego no devo deve assicurare
la casa a chiudere le porte no sono la
ragazza che è scomparsa quella di di cui
parlano i biglietti devo praticamente
mettere al sicuro la casa chiudendo le
finestre le porte ok bene o male da casa
l'ho già vista all'inizio quindi più o
meno mi ricordo come c'è la casa non è
proprio così enorme quindi teoria dovrei
riuscirci
fatemi passare bastardi ok siamo a due
finestre
no veramente quest'anno segue
porca [ __ ] ok
chiudi queste fottute finestre di merda
chiude questa è già chiusa cazzo è
veramente una cosa assurda
speriamo che non è intricato che queste
sono già chiuse la porta la portano la
porta no chiudi chiudi la porta
maledizione chiude cure perché non si
chiude ok siamo a 2 2 su 8 ragala cazzo
oh cazzo era un flash era soltanto un
flash cazzo chiude chiudi tutto a
chiudere qualsiasi cosa
chiude anche il frigo non voglio che
entri cazzo ma perché non riesco a
chiudere una porta perfetto 3 slot frigo
e chiuso perfetto no questa anche questa
anche fantastico quattro slot ora che
stiamo andando come dei razzi bene lì
non ci sono aperture mi ricordo perfetto
e andiamo andiamo nell'altra stanza
maledizione ci sono finestre aperte no
ok è traumatico se alla fine bottino no
chiude bastardi 26 su otto regole rai
che ho finito ho finito finito finito
finito finito tranquilli tranquilli
siamo al sicuro danimarca
[Musica]
e stato traumatizzante
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo rifacciamo
allora chiudiamo
innanzitutto la prima finestra allora la
casa come ho detto prima è piccola nel
senso che le porte dove riuscire a
chiuderla in due minuti massimo
il problema è che riesco a morire prima
c'è ma si può essere così scarsi vabbè
lasciamo stare
queste sono più diversi tranne questa
perfetta siamo già 26 traguardo 3
perfetto c'è qualcos'altro qui la vasca
da bagno no
ok devo andare di sotto per quella
aperta cazzo
no non è a pezzi a perla cazzo allora
siamo a 4 perfetto vedete che ci sto
mettendo un secondo soltanto che appare
subito è una cosa veramente fuori dal
mondo
a meno che non si abbiano risolto adesso
ci dovrei fare ok ok chiuditi bastarda
di merda brava
ok arriva arriva la parte vicino alla
sesta pagina che impossibile
bene allora questo ok questo che col è
chiuso ci siamo ci siamo c'è la porta di
dietro capelli già piena
ok siamo a 76 cazzo dicono sono anche
contare a 7 le manca una chiuditi 7 dai
già posso fare ce la fa sia questa e
queste queste queste queste queste
questo ok ok 88 ce la fa ai miglior rom
di nuovo cazzo saliamo no no no la
nutella e mia bastardo ok
saliamo saliamo saliamo saremo sala dove
al piano di sopra io trovo più di sopra
tradizione ok ok ok ci siamo ci siamo ci
siamo ci siamo tranquilli ok ci sono ci
sono perché la porta è chiusa a cazzano
chiusa io ok
chiuditi bastarda se no perché
perché mi ha scaraventato il muro mi ha
scaraventato al muro ma ce l'ho fatta
credo ce l'ho fatta perché doveva finire
così
doveva finire così vero doveva finire
così e che se noi lancio il monitor ok
ce l'abbiamo fatta raga è praticamente
questi erano ricordi ma non ero io vero
no era un'altra quella era quella che
era morta ok perfetto
veramente mi consola faresti pezzi qui
perché so che cosa mi aspetta adesso che
ci siamo giocati questo pezzo fantastico
torniamo nella foresta perché so che ci
aspettano a braccia aperte lo slider man
o invece no
devo andare di sopra cazzo che culo devo
andare di sopra raga devo seguire la
montagna quindi devo arrivare io penso
che l'obiettivo finale sia quella torre
lì come nella beta avevo detto c'è nella
beta io pensavo dovessi raggiungere quel
pezzo li devo raggiungere la torre e
penso sia una torre radio non lo so
comunque va beh fa molto alan wake sto
pezzo andiamo avanti
ebbene c'è un'altra caverna sotterrare
cos'è cos'è con l'affare che cazzo è una
scatola perché c'è la scatola chi è che
traslocherebbe in una caverna chi è quel
pazzoide dove cazzo sta andando
addio ho trovato ho trovato dei graffiti
primitivi raga fantastico un posto che
dal cenozoico che non è stato ritrovato
di harry vol
che cazzo c'è scritto yonhap hingis
harry ball minchia andiamo bene cos'è
starò a insozzano arienzo sorry for
every thing
si vabbè c'è tutta la spiegazione logica
la lista della spesa zucchine fagioli
dottoresse per la fine c'è scritto god
forgives ovvero dio perdonami mi fa
piacere e io uscirei da questo posto di
merda perché già non mi piace dove cazzo
siamo ho perso l'orientamento ok andiamo
avanti c'è un'uscita preghiamo che ci
sia un uscita perché non ce la faccio
più a rimanere qui ok che cazzo succede
sono entrato all'inferno è diventato
tutto rosso
che cazzo sta succedendo sta crollando
l'amore bottio mi sa che che cazzo
succede
oddio va tutto fuoco chiamati i pompieri
non c'è il cellulare cazzo non prende
non c'è campo aiuto cazzo perché sta
andando tutto a fuoco cos'è sta roba ma
che jackson
ok va bene non vado di là ho capito ci
sono gli alberi che si stanno stuprando
vicenda vado dalla parte opposta
oddio che cazzo è cosa cazzo est europa
oddio oddio dio dio dio via via via via
via via cos'è non lo so che cos'è ma non
mi piace andiamo avanti
oddio poi lo slalom tra gli alberi che
cazzo sta succedendo non lo so ok ci
sono dei tentacoli ci sono i tentacoli e
ce lo stand erben corri corri corri
corri corri con i cori carina sto dove
sto andando
non so dove sto andando non ne ho la piu
pallida diano qualsiasi fosse meglio di
questo caso sono all'inferno barche che
ha dato fuoco non si gettano le
sigarette nel bosco bastardo
ok siamo arrivati quasi alla torre la
gal esistiamo ce l'abbiamo quasi fatta
cazzo è traumatizzante sto pezzo ok
ce la possiamo fare oddio cosa non gli
alberi guardano gli alberi sto ancora
correndo ce la possiamo fare oddio braga
è una cosa veramente assurda non so
neanche perché sto facendo tutto questo
ci siamo ci siamo ok ok ok
il piano ha leggermente sbattuto la
porta
cazzo è traumatizzante sto pezzo aiuto
apri apri ok cosa devo fare qui è stato
veramente un delirio andiamo avanti alla
nostra porta è chiusa
messa si apre si perfetto cos'è che
cazzo sono munizioni magari avessi una
pistola in questo magari ho preso una
chiave perfetto
[Musica]
ok non c'è
nessuno non c'è nessuno non c'è andiamo
avanti andiamo avanti piano
non so se non so se lo zio che cazzo era
il cazzo è non lo so lo andiamo avanti
andiamo avanti diamanti corni non solo
dove proviene il rumore sinceramente non
lo so ma io proseguo perchè io li ferma
non ci sto ok c'è un'altra porta raga
pieno di porta your flash light is dead
cazzo mia morte la torcia ma non è che
chiodi cazzo chiodi e chi è che apre la
porta vasta chi è quello ai beni
sta sfondando ok hi fi fendi o chi è
questo dio no dovrebbe essere il marito
della tipa che controllo questo è morto
carbonizzato cazzo ok c'è una
videocamera la prendo sì
è finito perfetto che cazzo è stato o
cazzo ok ok io ti do qualche [ __ ] no
ti prego no non sfondare che cosa è
successo
no non ci credo è finito così non può
finire così non può finire così che
finale di merda ma no beh se lo decide
slider man ok o mio dio è stato il gioco
più traumatizzante di sempre
questo fino ad ora mi sento di dire che
è stato il gioco this lander man
migliore che sia uscito devo dire a
parte gli infarti di stupratori e tutto
il resto devo dire che mi è piaciuto
non vedo l'ora che esca o faceless o the
intruder che sono gli altri hughes
lander che ho in mente di giocare ma
pensa usciranno più avanti niente direi
che posso chiudere qui è stata veramente
un'esperienza assurda
vabbè dai raga come al solito se vi dove
è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come non i
video trovate nella descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo il prossimo video bella ragazzi